told the function G is defined over the
real numbers this table gives a few
values of G so for a few values of x to
give us what g of x is equal to and they
say what is a reasonable estimate for
the limit of G of X as X approaches 9
from the left or as X approaches 9
remember when we say X approaches 9 with
this little superscript that little
negative sign that doesn't necessarily
mean that we're approaching 9 from
negative values of x it means that we're
approaching 9 from values less than nine
and so to think about this what is a
reasonable value for the left-sided or
the left-handed limit which all right
let's pick some X values that get closer
at that are less than 9 but keep getting
closer and closer to nine so I would
look at these X values which they seem
to have chosen to do exactly that
they're starting at eight point nine and
they get even closer 8.99 then they get
even closer to eight point nine nine
nine and once again they only want us to
figure out whether we can estimate the
left-handed limit if we wanted to know
the actual limit we would want to figure
out the left-handed limit and the
right-handed limit and to feel good that
they seem to be approaching the same
thing but here we're only talking about
the left-handed so when I look at this
at 8.9 G of X is equal to negative 5.01
as we get even closer to nine we get to
negative 4.83 as we get even closer to
nine we get to negative 4.81 so just
looking at these three values here for
these three X's it looks like we're
getting we're getting close to about
negative four point eight so it's
approximately negative four point eight
now we don't know that for sure it's
often times the limit might end up being
a nice number like negative four point
eight and that's not that nice of a
number but the limit might be negative
four point eight zero zero two four
three eight that where you are
approaching it doesn't always have to go
to a nice a nice to look at number but
something interesting happens when we
get exactly the nine
all of a sudden it seems like we're
getting we get further away from
negative 4.8 we jump to negative 5.3 so
what does that tell us well this is
actually trying to tackle a key
misconception that folks have when
trying to think about limits a limit is
the value that you are approaching a
value that the function is approaching
as X approaches a certain value it isn't
necessarily going to be what the
function is defined at that value so you
can be approaching a different value
than what the function is defined at and
it looks at least looking at inspecting
this table it looks like that's what's
happening here so what is a reasonable
limit what is a reasonable estimate for
the left-handed limit as X approaches 9
of G of X well I would rule out negative
5.3 even though that is what G of nine
is this is equal to G of nine as we
approach from the left it does not look
like we are approaching negative 5.3 so
in fact it looks like we're getting
further and further away or where it
looks like we're approaching negative
4.8 and we're actually as we get closer
and closer we're getting a little bit
further from something like negative 5.3
so I would rule this one out negative
4.8 I liked even before I looked at the
choices it looked like that's what we
were approaching so that seems like a
reasonable estimate I like that so 4.7
so 4.7 let's see is is that Ariza ok so
this is tricky at first I was like oh
yeah maybe but I realize this isn't
negative 4.7 if it was negative 4.7 well
maybe that would be reasonable we don't
know for sure but it's not it's 4.7 so
there's no reason why we would be
approaching negative 4 point a and all
of a sudden jump to 4.7 and that'd be
the limit that's not what we're
approaching we're not approaching a
positive 4.7 so definitely rule that out
and we're definitely not approaching 9
here they're just trying to confuse you
the X is approaching 9 from the left
from values less than 9 but that's not
what the function itself is approaching
the function itself seems to be getting
closer and closer negative 4.8 so rule
that one out and the limit seems to
exist once again we are estimating when
we have the
these tables it's completely up possible
that this is some type of weird function
that begins to do some type of weird
oscillation as we get really close so it
oscillates between negative 4.8 and
negative 4.7 so we don't know one
hundred percent sure but it's reasonable
it's not reasonable to think based on
this information that the limit doesn't
exist so I would rule that out and I
like this choice right over here now
let's do one more example a student
created a table to help them reason
about the limit as X approaches 3 of f
of X and so here we want the actual
limits we want the limit as we approach
from the left and from the right and see
if we are approaching the same thing
based on the table what can you reason
about the limit so here we see X
approaching we could say from below so
visually it looks like from above we're
approaching x from the left we're
approaching ex from values we're
approaching i should say we're
approaching three from values to the
left of three if we were on the if we're
looking at the x axis or approaching
three from values less than three and it
looks like see 2.9 negative 1.28 2.99
negative one point four to two point
nine nine nine nine negative 1.49 so it
looks like we're getting closer and
closer to negative 1.5 negative 1.5 and
even though 3 is under even though the
function is undefined at x equals 3 the
limit could exist in fact that's one of
the main values of a limit they say what
is a function approaching even in cases
where the function is not defined there
so it looks like it's approaching
negative 1.5 now if we approach if we
approach 3 from the positive direction
from values greater than 3 see when we
get 3.1 then our function is negative
1.83 point 01 our function is negative
1.63 make 3.00 one- 1.51 so even from
the right or even from values large and
three it still looks like we're
approaching negative 1.5 so this could
be a reasonable estimate a reasonable
guess based on this table of what the
limit actually is now we have to be very
very careful you don't know definitively
just by trying out these numbers the
limit is definitely negative 1.5 it
might be negative 1 point
five one eight seven repeating it might
be that number we don't know for sure
now in a typical calculus class in a
typical exam you don't typically see
numbers like that you're the questions
are usually engineered to give you nice
or numbers but I just want to make it
clear you might be approaching you might
be approaching in a rational number you
could be approaching you know a pi
divided by two or something like that
not necessary in this case but in
general so but this is a reasonable
estimate so let's see what we can reason
so limit as X approaches 3 of f of x is
approximately negative 1.5 yeah I think
this is a reasonable thing so I would
check that off now we don't know this
for sure in fact there's even a scenario
with just limit still might not exist
even if it looks like it may be as we
get closer and closer this is some type
of weird function that starts
oscillating in some strange way or the
stops getting closer and closer to a
value even though it looks like it's
getting closer and closer right over
here but this is a reasonable what can
you reasonably reason I'll put that here
what can you reasonably a reasonably
reason about the limit there appears to
be an asymptote at x equals 3 well no an
asymptote it would be the situation if
we were a vertical asymptote especially
is if we are seem to be approaching
infinity or negative infinity and that's
definitely not the case here so I'll
rule that out as we approach x equals 3
the values of f of X seem to approach
negative 1.5 but we can't say for sure
if that's the limit exactly yeah that's
the point I was making right over here
it seems like it's getting the negative
1.5 and most tests on most most
questions on those tests are kind of
engineered to give you numbers that
aren't crazy but even with this data
even with this information it might be
approaching something a little bit more
more interesting or this could be some
kind of crazy function that as we get
within a thousandth of three it maybe
it's not defined even around three maybe
it's not even to find a two point nine
nine nine nine nine or three point zero
zero zero zero one or maybe it's just
not doesn't get closer anymore so once
again you don't know for sure but this
does say this does seem to be a
reasonable thing to say the values of f
of X appear to oscillate jump back and
forth
your x equals 3 so it's hard to say what
the limit is or if it even exists well
we're not seeing that behavior right
over here so I wouldn't pick that that's
not a reasonable thing because you're
not observing it in the data now there
are some crazy functions out there where
all of a sudden if you start trying out
values that are much closer than what
we're seeing here maybe some of this
behavior starts to happen but we're not
seeing it in the data so I definitely
wouldn't pick that